I dont want to give it away. It was the butler.  The butler did it. leave my books alone. Okay. Just let me read
What brings you across the pond it's my honeymoon, where's your husband? dead
Asleep. dead asleep
Sir, if you don't return to your seat, I'm gonna have to call cops
Hey
we've actually been married for 15 years, but we're just very, very, very, very busy
Charles is inviting us to spend the weekend with him on a yacht
Audrey fool around on a boat. I just lay here and the boat does all the work
Should we pull it up now. It's a foot long my husband he's a detective. How could it better? Don't put it back
My name is inspector Laurent De Lacroix, I will now summon you for questioning. Oh
Why is that smoking so could he do that?
Did you notice anything out of the ordinary? Yeah
What we didn't do this someone's trying to frame us
We do things together. So can we please just figure this out?
They died, so it's called death library
Someone do you think that's possible with trying
Those were warning shots honey, I do this we gotta look confident
I Love you l love you sweet